from day one of the Donald Trump
Republican tax cuts
I've been reminding the audience and
imploring and begging people to
understand how these corporate tax cuts
will be used they will not be used to
create jobs they will not be used in
ways that will be good for the economy
at large or for the average worker we
knew from the beginning that these
corporate tax cuts were going to be used
by big companies to buy back company
stock to drive up the share price and
they will be used for companies that
have plans of automating away jobs
offshoring jobs leaving the United
States with manufacturing facilities the
tax cut money will be used to accelerate
that companies hire when there's more
demand for their products if you give
corporations and rich people tax cuts
that doesn't generate more demand for
their products and Walmart is a great
example of this this is yet another one
of these data points which I will tell
you about momentarily that confirms
exactly every single one of our
predictions about how these tax cuts
would work a great example of this that
we already knew about from before the
tax cuts was remember that huge victory
that Donald Trump and Mike Pence claimed
before Trump was even in raw inaugurated
Trump claimed to have made a big deal to
keep a an air conditioning factory I
believe it was carrier I'm going from
memory here carrier in Indiana maybe it
was Ohio but I think it was Indiana and
from said we made a deal they are now
going to stay because they believe in
the business environment that we will
have under the Trump administration or
whatever it wasn't a deal Trump just
gave them money
that's not economic policy it's here
take some cash and ultimately once we
got past the propaganda carrier still
decided to move jobs out of the United
States and still decided to continue
moving forward on the automation of many
of the jobs that they plan to automate
for a while before Donald Trump handed
them some cash we even heard from
company executives that they would be
using some of that money to continue
moving in the direction of automating
more of their jobs that was before
Donald Trump's tax cuts even went in
into effect Walmart has now announced
that
it will be laying off 570 employees in
North Carolina they're going to close
their corporate office near Charlotte's
Airport Walmart saved 1.6 billion
dollars in the first three quarters of
2018 thanks to Donald Trump's tax cuts
according to the New York Times and the
bigger picture estimate is that Donald
Trump's corporate tax cut will save
Walmart about 2.2 billion dollars per
year this is why you can't fall for the
headline about bonuses that companies
are paying because of Trump's tax cuts
or wage increases or whatever Trump and
other right-wingers made a huge deal of
Walmart paying some employees these
thousand dollar bonuses all thanks to
Donald Trump's wise and incredibly
intelligent tax cuts Donald Trump would
talk about it all the time back in
January of 2018 2018 he would retweet
stuff like this clip from his friend
Maria Bartiromo
over at Fox Business Network in January
of 2018 claiming massive victory at
Walmart because of the tax cuts take a
look
trickle-down tax reform Walmart the
country's largest private employer just
announced major changes saying that it
will raise its u.s. minimum wage to $11
an hour it will pay a one-time bonus of
up to $1,000 to hourly workers and it
will expand maternity and parental leave
benefits President Trump spoke more
about the positives of tax reform during
his cabinet meeting yesterday Wow
$11 per hour and a thousand dollar
bonuses which by the way still doesn't
take most of those employees out of the
federal poverty level of income and then
hours later after that video after that
announcement Walmart announced it was
going to close 63 Sam's club stores they
were laying off thousands of people and
by the way they all of a sudden had
twenty billion dollars to do a stock
buyback which is really great for their
executives and it's really great for
their big shareholders this is how it
works okay this is not a bug this is a
feature of how these tax cuts are
designed to work Qualcomm did the same
thing they did a ten billion dollar
stock buy
back and laid off 1,500 people in
California this is why it is correct for
people like Bernie Sanders and Andrew
yang and Elizabeth Warren to be going
after these companies that pay no taxes
or pay very little in taxes and then
they lay people off and then they
automate jobs and then they do stock
buybacks and they are completely
subsidized by the government
which subsidizes their low wages for
their employees with various welfare
programs and I want to be super clear
here that I'm being understood about
what my view is of course companies are
going to do this if they are allowed to
do it this isn't about anything other
than restructuring the regulatory
environment and what these companies are
allowed to do and understanding that in
order to fix the problem we have in this
country of inequality and a system of
government justice of everything for the
rich and corporations and a different
system for what we might call the
underclasses
we are going to need to seriously
rethink more than just should the
minimum wage be eleven twelve or fifteen
dollars like that that's not going to
solve the problem okay we're not talking
about taking these companies out of
business okay they wouldn't be good for
the economy for Amazon and carrier and
whatever companies you want a name to go
out of business that's not what we're
targeting that's not what Social
Democrats want they employ people they
provide products that people want and
need what I am saying is that they can
pay their fair share period they can
play by tighter rules period and what
you have to understand is that the anti
socialism movement on the right is a red
herring bad faith movement partially
because anything they don't like they
just call socialism and we've talked
about that before but they actually
benefit from the closest things to
socialist policies that exist in the
United States the closest thing we have
to socialism is the way in which
corporate America's costs are socialized
through welfare programs and corporate
welfare but the profits are all theirs
we talked about this with environmental
disasters okay it's extremely common in
the United States that environmental the
disasters for fossil fuel companies and
energy companies it's capitalism for the
profits to their corporations to their
to the corporations and then it's
socialism for the cleanup costs for the
damage they do to the environment okay
this has to stop
we have said it before and I'll say it
again this is bigger than a $15 minimum
wage this is bigger than family a paid
Family Medical Leave this has to be a
bigger restructuring of our
relationships to work and the corporate
corporate regulatory environment you're
not going to get it from Republicans
you're not going to get it from centrist
Democrats that's an important thing we
talked yesterday on the show how Joe
Biden was caught caught he said behind
closed doors to rich donors in New York
City but I I I'm gonna be loyal to you I
need you
nothing significantly is going to change
for you centrist Democrats are not going
to change this they'll throw some crumbs
while letting the rich keep their big
rich decadent cakes as I said yesterday
and they'll throw some cake crumbs to
the lower lower middle and middle class
something else is going to need to
change and most candidates basically
every Republican and centrist Democrats
don't even want to admit that our
problems are bigger than bringing back
some manufacturing jobs or increasing
the minimum wage to 15 bucks you're not
dealing with the systemic issues let me
know what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show I will be taking your phone
calls shortly I will also be dealing
later on in the show with a very
interesting audience question about
isolationism versus non-interventionism
they are very different things and the
political domestic political and
geopolitical implications of one versus
the other are drastically different
that's coming up a little bit later
today one of today's sponsors is impeach
the card slap game you cannot slap
Donald Trump in real life but you can
slap him in this hilarious fast-paced
two-player card game and you can get it
for 10% off when you go to david
pakman.com slash impeach and
use the coupon code pakman show at
checkout all one word awesome for
parties when you're having a few drinks
I've been playing it with some friends
of mine currently has a 5 out of 5 star
rating on Amazon and it combines clever
satire about the Trump administration
with really funny high-quality cartoon
artwork all in a really lively card game
that's easy to learn but it stays
interesting every time you play it
because of how well designed it is and
really how much thought went into the
humor and the political commentary the
game covers a ton of themes global
warming Russian collusion tax cuts for
the wealthy impeach the cards slap game
is perfect if you're looking for
something fun and casual to do with your
politically minded friends or family
members you might even learn something
new about the Trump administration while
you're playing the game it's a perfect
gift for anyone who has a sense of humor
about Trump or get it for yourself and
have a really fun and witty game to play
when people come over you can even play
a tournament style get impeach the card
slap game by going to david pakman.com
slash impeach and get 10% off when you
use the coupon code pakman show at
checkout all one word